for that i can't disagree too much there
you go you know i like the eagles i like
slaying i got a couple players over
there that can make some time
yeah the kobe dean we got jordan davis
on that defense now five's a lot asking
for it on the road i still really like
this eagles team so solid be solid i
would if i would have brought a b home
to my mom she would have been happy if i
would she would definitely be if i would
have got an f right off the bat from
calvin i don't know if i could continue
the show
all right so the
next bet that i have for you calvin
big thing especially early in the season
division dogs and i think that's going
to be a theme for me coming up this is a
tricky one though but i really really
like this my second bet that i love is
the steelers plus six and a half on the
road against the defending afc champs
we're going to talk about this a lot you
and i oh yeah oh you like the steelers
oh yes and we get it you said in which
we trust in our last show
i'm not as high but i don't think mitch
will lose the steelers games and i love
everything around him the only worry is
that offensive line offensive line is
pretty tough the steelers that defense
is nasty those wide receivers george
pickens in the mix now loved him at
georgia uh i know we don't want to we
don't want to hype up georgia too much
uh
no and and this is not like a knock on
the bengals at all joe burrow absolutely
love them jamar chase i think they're
going to be great did see a little bit
of a super bowl hangover
from the team that played on thursday
night maybe we see a little bit of that
today yeah i just think six and a half
division game and yes they blew them out
last year in cincinnati i think it was
41 to 10.
big ben was their quarterback big ben
was the queen and i think that was a
hindrance to that team i really like the
steelers today i think getting six and a
half is wonderful calvin calvin six and
a half on the steelers
he's shuffling up those cards he's
thinking
you think the stillers
keep it close against the bangles it's
the bengals super bowl hangover no i'm
not oh it's a little too close for me
that's a little too close i'm not
comfortable with that yeah that's a
little too close for me you feeling like
a ten point bengals win by ten something
like that i'm definitely feeling that
yeah yeah he thinks it's a blowout i
mean i'm not super comfortable with what
still steelers got going on right now
mitch trubisky he's a great i think he's
not not great he's a good uh clock
manager for the team he's a good manager
there is he gonna go out and win you a
game i got to see him play a lot against
uh uh against detroit uh and he's beat
detroit sometimes yeah but i'm not sure
if he's going to be able to do enough to
pull those guys to hold the bengals yeah
so no super bowl hangover you you think
they're just going to go week one and bi
i got confidence in joe burrow i got
confidence in the lsu boys over there
hey calvin has confidence ritter do you
have confidence in your next it i do
because my next pick again is another
divisional dog this time at home
and you know we had to do it vikings and
i'm taking the plus one i'm getting that
plus one against attackers that line is
now actually flipped they are now one
and a half point favorites at home okay
and i know aaron rodgers aaron rodgers
again i love this vikings team we'll
probably talk about them later uh i have
a lot of faith in your cousins and i
know you're going to laugh and that's
fair uh michael and the reason the
reason i am taking the plus one instead
of just taking them outright to win is
if you have bet the vikings in the last
two years you know that they love to
lose close games and the most
excruciating ways by i'm sure you've had
some games against them in the past
because their quarterback is
because
no they miss kicks they give up safeties
and weird times it's just such a weird
team i'm taking that extra insurance in
case they lose by one i get to push but
no i think the vikings win today at home
i i feel good about it i'm just taking
that little insurance play with the plus
one division matchup division master
your division it's in my division um i'm
feeling you on that though i'm feeling
you i'm gonna give you a b on that
because i like what um i like what the
vikings doing they got the lsu boys you
got jefferson over there the bad boy
yeah he's a bad boy not the best one in
the league he's definitely top two
probably so uh i like what they got guys
got going over there that receiving core
strong they're running back everybody's
healthy on the vikings they got a good
chance of winning the game honestly and
my my biggest thing with the packers too
is i think the packers the thing that's
going to keep them in games obviously
aaron rodgers that defense is really
good this year they're that's going to
keep them in game so a little worried
about that today don't love the vikings
offensive line but i just i see a high
scoring game today and i think the
vikings offense is better than the
packers offense we're going to have to
see if those wide receivers that are in
green bay if they step up to the call
with aaron rodgers let's move on michael
ritter let's move on to your next pick
okay this is a big one for me and you're
not gonna like this more than anyone i
know you didn't like the vikings pick
but you know what's coming i think i
know what's coming calvin a little a
little inside info about me i am of all
teams a las vegas raiders home
unfortunately and it's a big game today
some would say a home game because it's
in los angeles it might be a home game
and i thought about it it's three and a
half is the spread but i felt that would
be pretty disingenuous if i actually
gave out points on my favorite team so
we're taking the raiders money line
that's what the bet is today
i think they get it done today
obviously justin herbert
terrifies me my the the quarterbacks in
my division now are terrifying i had to
go up against bones and herbert now
russell wilson added to the mix i just
love this raiders team now i get the
defensive concerns again i think this is
another high scoring game today i think
the chargers not having jc jackson it's
a big deal and there's a there's a new
receiver for the las vegas raiders who i
think is going to have a massive game
today
i love the raiders in a home game in los
angeles
what about that defense though michael
ritter what about that raiders defense
do you think they did anything to
address
that problem that they have out there so
the pass rush was really good last year
they obviously at trader for chandler
jones max crosby is a beast yes
obviously the concern is still the
secondary linebackers still uh i think
they're gonna get after herbert today i
think it's a high scoring game they beat
him last year in a high scoring game the
last game of the season
i love the raiders today
this is this is middle of the pack for
me i'm gonna give you a c on this okay
you know mama's not gonna kill you for
the scene
he's getting degrees
but it's hard man
to see um that chargers going against
that defense that's the secondary you
know that quarterback going against that
secondary for the uh raiders yeah i'm
not sure how they're going to hold up
against them you know i love that they
have devonta over there now back with uh
the car you know it'd be great to see i
hope the chemistry is already there but
man what they got going on that offense
over there in charge is something
special especially with that quarterback
very special very very special i will i
will talk as much trash in the division
but
every team there's one team i don't like
in that division and i'll maybe we'll
touch on that later but
just playing my homes twice a year
playing herbert now i mean it's it's
gonna be tough but it's definitely gonna
ride with my team okay this next bet
from a fifth bet we love
a teaser do we know what a teaser is
there i'll explain it but this is a big
it's a big kind of touch point in the
betting world yeah teaser is fair foul
so basically you get to set your own
line in a parlay so i like to do is i
like to take a few teams that are
touchdown favorite and tease them down
so it's all you have to do is they just
need to win and that's what i'm doing
today there are three teams that are six
and a half point favorites today and i
like them all i maybe would bet them on
the spread but i just need them to win
today for this all three of them and
that is i am taking a ravens 49ers
chiefs six point t's so if all those
teams win plus 160 on that that is my
teaser today so
i love the ravens today i just got a
weird feeling the jets really fun draft
that they just had might stick with it
obviously you know zack wilson just to
be safe teasing them down love the 49ers
against the bears today but again rookie
quarterback on the road
the trailing its error is here it's here
it's gonna play it safe
and then again with the chiefs
not really a good against the spread
team they've kind of danced around
especially early in the year last year
struggled in games cardinals are a big i
have no idea what they're to be like
yeah especially after just going to
tease them down chiefs win 49ers win
rams win we get our money what do you
think i like that i would uh give you an
a on that pick i would agree with that
100
hey hey calvin gave him the a plus i
don't know if y'all saw but that was the
eight there was no a i don't have an
eight
i wish i had that i added the plus right
before let's make sure i got one and he
gave him the a the a plus on that one i
actually do like that teaser ritter yeah
you guys follow that season because i i
like that one 160 plus 160 all they need
to do is win i'll all through this team
all they got to do is just win shout out
to my man michael ritter with the spa
right of the day right there hey last
one
all right so you really liked you like
that one yeah this is where i think i
might get my first half so i always have
to take a big money line underdog and
there's no better time to take it than
week one it always feels like every year
there's that one game it's like who won
right they lost to who
and i have that team today and they are
the biggest underdogs of the week and i
am taking them on the money line love
the points i am taking the houston
texans to beat the indianapolis colts
today on the money line on the money
line no points on the money
dejected right now he i can already tell
what's coming on this one
the indianapolis colts everywhere he's
so mad at me the indianapolis colts
consistently early in the year it's and
i know matt ryan's here now i'm excited
for this team i think they can win the
division but i don't know i got a weird
feeling about this game everyone's like
just throwing the colts in a teaser
they'll beat the texans texans are this
set
i thought davis mills was actually okay
last year like i didn't think he was
losing them games
love you smith as the head coach it's in
houston
eight and a half point favorites at home
ritter you're trying to win us over bro
i'm i'm trying i try he's trying valiant
effort so what do you think
texans money line anyone anyone matt
ryan's macgyver yeah you know so matt
brown
i think the super bowl hangover is over
that's a couple years ago you know i
don't think we're gonna have
have that kind of
a drop-off again from him um i don't see
that happening i don't i don't i can't
fathom that this with the the team
jonathan taylor you know if you get
those guys humming man i just don't see
him who's the quarterback for the texans
davis mills
the legend
the legend
the legend yeah there it is he gave it
to f minus i agree with him uh i like
the points yeah but the money line why
not
why not you know
i love the eight and a half love the
eight and a half
i'm being risky i understand it i'll
take my f minus i've gotten a few of
those in my lifetime so hey you're
looking my face i hope you can now you
got more more good grades to bring home
to mom than bad grades my mom if i know
you're watching i think i this is a
passing grade right you're not going to
yell at me for this one i think calvin
johnson somewhat approved yeah
hey uh
let me hop into the comments let me hop
into the comments because we want to
talk to the people yeah yeah calvin they
want to talk to you uh uh lefko is in
the comments let go says megatron is
wrong bird soar in detroit all love
megatron shout out to our man adam lefko
burgers leave in the winter time baby
it's time to migrate they out of there
hey uh great g8 is in the comments
talking to my man michael ritter he says
that kirk cousins future is a donation
for sure and i
absolutely agree with him yeah
it's definitely a donation i got one
more colin frost is in the comments and
fly eagles fly uh ryan's gonna like that
one our our producer ryan is gonna like
that one uh let's transition make sure
you guys drop your super bowl locks in
the comments for a chance to go to vegas
uh calvin now it's your time to shine
man you're gonna help us pick a anytime
td score today that we are all going to
ride with as a family and our friends at
draftkings actually boosting this one
for us so uh let's pull up the graphic
there it there it is
we're savings calvin's pick for last
because he's picking the squad right
that's going to get the odds boost but
i'm going to start it off
you guys see that guy that's third on
the list christian mccaffrey
yep he's going to see the ball in his
hands a lot today so i'm going to rock
with christian mccaffrey to get in the
end zone today
that's why i'm rocking with michael
ritter we want to know who you're
rockaway and then we're going to go to
the man cal yeah so pulling up that
graphic right there i see a quarterback
on there who i have in my teaser today
that i love i think lamar gets in the
end zone today talking about being
motivated coming off this past week with
the news i would love to see him not one
two touchdowns today against the jets
also lamar historically week one loves
to go off i'd i'd expect a big game from
martin i think he gets in the end zone i
think plus 125 for him is great i could
definitely see lamar getting an end zone
he wants a contract he wants the money
he deserves that money he definitely
does deserve it yeah hey
the squad ride of the day this is what
we are all riding today
drum roll calvin what are we riding with
today what's the pick
jonathan tatum oh
jonathan taylor the biggest
my man's calvin's rocking with jonathan
taylor and you guys know what we do
around here
we're going to boost that here drafting
is going to help us we're going to boost
that from minus 230 up to plus 100
that's even money that is a big boost
shout out to draftkings for doing that
uh let me get back into the chat though
because the people want to talk to you
they want to know
what's going on uh
i got eli jones in the comments you're
talking to my man michael ritter dude
ritter is a genius he's right about all
his picks wow
thank you eli shout out to eli uh three
eats three each says super bowl lock is
the cowboys versus the bills
and third time's the charm for buffalo
calvin do you think the bills has what
it takes to win the championship this
year i definitely just i mean off of
that little snapshot that we got on
thursday night they definitely had the
pieces but um
i'm not sure about the other side of it
the nfc oh yeah
yeah i don't know about that either uh
hey i'm gonna teach you about a new bet
we like that we like to make new bets
around here get the people uh early wins
is what we like we like early wins we
like to win bets early so we got a new
bet called early win
calvin the basically the gist of the bet
is if you bet on a team and they go up
by by 10 points okay they go by 10
points at any time of the ball game you
win they can even lose the game all they
got to do is just go up by 10 points and
you win um
with that being said with that being
said which team do you think today
will go up by 10
points
what team today is going to go up by 10
points who did i have on my list today
to go up by 10
who go get the early win what
was it the ravens was it the ravens the
ravens it's a good one i think
the jets that definitely was the ravens
yeah yeah yeah that's easy
money that's it that's it easy money you
think it's going to be a track meet out
there it should be i want to i want to
see lamar go get it all right this year
i want to see him kill it
hey he said the ravens michael ritter
it's your turn who do you think is going
to go up 10 today my team the raiders
players are going up 10 right off the
bat because they're winning today
hey that's a head scratcher hey
hey lost money too less money yeah i
wonder who you're going with you already
know man
we go hey i'm rocking with the niners
man it's gonna be a track meeting uh
chicago uh so uh that's what we rock
away we're rocking with the niners they
going up 10. i think i think it's going
to get nasty out there everybody talk
about trey lance there's trey last night
you all go see trey lands today i look
forward to seeing but i have to go back
on that track meet in chicago because
they don't take care of that field
[Laughter]
get on dk and get your early win bet in
uh they're running it back tomorrow also
so don't miss out and if you're a new
customer you can bet five dollars and
get two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly sign up on draftkings and if
you don't believe me
you know that is right that's kevin hart
believe kevin hart uh
our own natalie bo day i got that right
our own natalie bo day has has a chance
to talk to the director of draft king
sports book johnny avello so let's let's
take a look
natalie bodie here with the director of
the draftkings sportsbook johnny avello
johnny welcome to the show we're so
happy to have you
thank you natalie it's good to be here
so we know you have the inside scoop so
let's get right into it i want to know
which line has moved the most since odds
were released
well there have been a few but for very
different reasons uh the ravens at the
jets went from four minus four to minus
seven
but that was due to the news that zach
wilson would not play in week one and
that's now confirmed that he won't so
that thing may continue to go higher
the game that moved the most
was the broncos at the seahawks because
we had that up before the trade
and so seattle went from a four point
favorite to a six and a half point
underdog
so russell wilson was worth five and a
half points of seattle which was taken
away and added to the broncos side for
an 11 point swing so those are the two
were based on you know no money being
bad but based on money coming in the
browns went from three and a half
road favorite to one and a half underdog
at carolina and in another significant
move because of money the chiefs from
three to six at arizona
well that's great to know kind of along
those same lines which bet has been the
most popular for week one
uh so far the bill's money line that's
the thursday night opener laying 1.30 to
win the game straight up that's a very
popular choice
and one prop alan robinson the second in
the same game over 62 and a half
receiving yards now i find that to be a
nice piece of handicap and by the
betters as robinson is in his ninth
career year
hasn't had a decent quarterback to throw
him the football and i believe after
it's all said and done you know what's
going to happen is that game will
continue to be bet but the sunday night
will be the most popular game biggest
right of the weekend uh that's an
isolated game and look for big handle
there
so now we're gonna take a look back and
i'm curious in your opinion
what was the worst week one upset ever
wow there's been many through the years
uh
you know the bills beating the pats back
in the early 2000s i think 2001
uh but after that loss the patriots went
on to win in the super bowl or maybe
even a couple in a row
remember natalie last year the underdogs
went nine and seven straight up in week
one last year that was unprecedented
never have seen that before
so i'm curious now i know i'm guilty of
this maybe some people at home are too
but have you seen a hard knocks effect
with people wanting to bet on the lions
at all
well in the michigan area a big yes to
that
you know the coach motor city dan
campbell is portrayed on this show as a
really nice guy and is all business and
i feel you know he has a lot of lions
fans and
you know under his belt now and
he's showing the viewers that he's
taking the team to a higher level
plus they oh they plus they now have
natalie slim shady on the sidelines
and he's ready to play any position so
he says so
i guess yes
so across the board who is your biggest
mvp liability
to the season starting our biggest
hazard for mvp is trey lance uh he's
currently at 25 to 1.
you know this 22 year old has very
limited experience both in college and
in pros
but he does have a formidable supporting
cast surrounding him uh not too far far
behind him lan you know lance's uh the
liability is on lamar jackson also his
odds are currently around 20 to 1.
so now we want to know what is new on
the dk menu for this upcoming season
we have this new promotion for week one
called seven up
uh and no natalie we're not giving away
free soda that's not it
uh if you bet on a team on the money
line
and they go up by seven points at any
time they're in the game you win even if
they end up losing the game
and then we're also extending that
promotion for the entire nfl season but
it'll be called 10 up
same rules apply but it's 10 point
criteria
for anybody interested go to the dk site
and see all the rules and uh limits on
how much you can bet
that's definitely exciting news always
great insight from you johnny thank you
so much for coming on the show
you're welcome natalie thank you natalie
thank you johnny let's transition uh
calvin you hold the receiving yards
record enough we want to talk about if
that record possibly might be broken
this year you hold the record at 1
964 receiving yards last year cooper cup
came within 17 yards away of breaking
the record very close very close very
close uh this year dk is offering
they're offering a chance to bet on
whether the record will be broken or not
uh the odds are yes it's plus 350 no
it's minus 450
what's is that a good bet like do you
think anybody's gonna do it
the only reason why i say it's possible
is because of matthew stafford
and cooper cup has matthew stafford
again and they were very close last year
so as long as those guys are healthy i
mean if you could average 100 yards a
game you put yourself damn close you
know as he did last year yeah you know
danny i was over there like damn he
might get it
and he was balling again the other day
too he was and he started off hot so i
mean that's all it takes you know and
they they haven't missed the stride it
seems like since uh last year so
they got a great chance yeah so if
obviously like cooper cup had a chance
to break it
i don't i personally don't i think it's
an untouchable record i think it's just
incredible that that's what you got to
but like when you look at the wide
receiver landscape so many good young
ride receivers if there were one of
these young guys to break your record
who do you think could break it um right
now just looking at a little bit of work
he's done but it seems like he has a
huge selling is jamar chase why because
he has a great quarterback with him you
know he has chemistry with that
quarterback and it kind of reminds me of
uh my myself and a young man young
matthew when we first started you know
but they go even further back because
they go back to college you know i look
forward to one seeing the kids do it and
you know by i mean i've had that record
for i don't know how many years now but
um you know to see somebody uh break it
that they have to get all the respect in
the world for me because i know how hard
it is to get there
yeah it's definitely hard but on that
note on that note let's talk some
betting let's talk receiving props for
today let's pull up the odds uh the odds
are coming up
there they are let's build a parlay each
of us is going to give one pick who is
going over their receiving yards today
uh i'm gonna start this one off guys i'm
going to start this one off with
somebody that's not on the list drake
london is playing uh he's playing over
there in in atlanta
and uh i think i think he's going to go
over i think they're going to feed him
the ball today they're going to try to
get their new rookie going uh so i think
he's going to go over his receiving
yards and it was low michael right it
was it was low so i it caught my eye so
i was like let me take that one up
who do you think who are you going to
add as a leg to the parlet so i like
that you're going with the rookie i i
think i think was 36 and a half for
yours i think i'm excited to watch drake
london i obviously i don't want to say
it was a reach but atlanta believes in
him clearly they took him very early in
the draft so i'm excited to watch him
i'm going with the established guy i'm
going chalk i'm going my team i think
devonte adams has a huge day today this
is 76 and a half
i mean i'm disliked i'm sorry thank you
thank you
hey palo alto guy yeah bay area guys
devonte adams i with jc jackson being
out for the chargers again the chemistry
with derek carr i think devante has a
huge day today that's my pick for our
play so we got
drake london drake london devonta dante
adams
and jamar chase there it is sticking
with the female man's rocking with jamar
chase you think he's going to get off
well you talked about it already we
literally just talked about it joe
burrow they they go back to lsu like
they go back but um that that's 70 it's
not even really close to what his uh
average is going to end up being even
like you just have a a year of a
snapshot of this picture of what his
time in the league but over the course
of time that's 70. his average is gonna
be well well above that well above it
let's put up the odds because i want you
guys at home to see if you were to put
this bet in what you will be walking
away with there it is if you put a
hundred dollars down
there it is you guys see it on your
screen
uh plus plus five five three is the odds
let me go back to the chat and please
remember to drop your super bowl locks
because we need your super bowl locks if
you guys want to go to vegas i'm back
into the chat though i'm back into the
chat see flores michael ritter nation
just win baby michael renner is getting
a lot of love
fans out there
michael michael ritter is getting a lot
of love in the comments uh i got
bakedtown baketown's in the comments
says calvin should bet some money that
the raiders don't win oh it's trying to
get a little rivalry going i could do
that okay we can do that
calvin johnson
is michael ritter live here at uh at
foxwood yeah spain you and foxwoods all
right we got one more one more
i see uh
frank j frank pj says jonathan taylor
anytime touchdown is a major lock today
he's rocking with the squad ride um
hey we were just talking about hard
knocks we were just talking about hard
knocks so
everybody's actually been talking about
hard knocks and they've been talking
about the lines lion's love everybody's
been saying that mine's going to get
love this year i want to ask you guys
are we showing love to the lions do we
think they're going to get over six and
a half wins this season that's what
their line is here at draftkings it's
six and a half do we think they're gonna
get over or under calvin first off did
you watch hard knocks and do you think
the lions is gonna go over or under six
and a half the only reason i watch hard
or nice is because my brother-in-law
he's watching every episode so
something caught my attention and made
me laugh so i like all right let me peep
this out because i am a dan campbell fan
played with him in detroit before uh
before uh he left and uh went on to do
great things in the coaching atmosphere
which he's doing right now but uh
yeah man it's been i've been fortunate
to be graced by his um
grace by him and i know that his players
respect the hell out of him because he
was a former player he was with he was
what they are right you know so he got
he has a lot of respect out of them but
those picks those numbers uh i saw maybe
eight on their on their schedule that
that they could possibly win that's
eight possibles but
i don't know if they don't get all those
possibles
it's like playing space i got i got like
three and four and five possible
hey he doesn't know if they're going to
win all those possibles michael ritter
do you think they might be able to win
some of those possibles and go over this
win total so looking at this number so i
think they won i mean they would have
the second overall pick in the draft
last year
i personally think like this number is
set perfectly i think they win six games
this year i think it's under i'm being
contrarian the public loves lines this
year i like the lines a lot obviously
betting against them today but i just
think like even if this team wins six
games and there's momentum going into
next year jamison williams comes back
and you have that healthy going into
next season another you know you're
aiding hutchinson jared goff again like
don't hate him i think he can like keep
you know went to a super bowl so i think
like i don't think this is the year just
yet and i think that's why the line is
the way it is but even if they win six
maybe they win seven i'm definitely
pulling for the lions this year we'll be
betting on them
not this week but in other weeks but i'm
gonna i'm gonna take the under i'm gonna
be the contrarian so michael ritter's
going with the under
i'm just going to connect the dots here
my man calvin was talking about the
coach he's talking about the coach and
how the coach is getting respected by
the players my man michael ritter said
that
they they're they're they're trying to
get some momentum going out there in
detroit these things are going to end at
six wins
i'm actually gonna go on the other side
i'm gonna think that they're gonna go
over six and a half wins simply because
i'm connecting the dots i the lions lost
a lot of close games last year they lost
a lot of close games last year the coach
the momentum
i think they're gonna go over six and a
half wins this year i think i think
they're gonna turn not turn it around
and become a playoff team but they're
gonna turn around to go in the different
direction than what they did last year
uh so i am rocking with the over calvin
they whispered in my ear
we need to know is it over or under
six and a half and we need
an answer
love you detroit i do i do but i don't
it ain't no playoff birthday that's the
show we know that you know back into
this yeah yeah ain't no super bowl
i don't see a playoff birth this year um
do i see eight wins not necessarily i do
see seven i want to go over okay um just
because i like what they have they
they're in a lot of their competitive
team um i'm hoping that they know how to
you know push over that hump and win a
little bit more you know get that up
under their up under uh
in their system you know get that taste
in their system know what it feels like
but they have to get there first they
don't have all the talent they need yet
so like you said another draft or two
yeah another year or two um we'll be
having a totally different conversation
probably i hope so hey love that we'll
see we will see in another year or two
but hey
we have uh some breaking news breaking
news we are closing the polls oh we are
closing the polls this is your last
opportunity last opportunity to drop
your super bowl picks for a chance to
win a trip to vegas get in there the
contest ends as soon as i count down
from five
four
three
two
one
that's it it's over
check out our convo with mike golick jr
and we'll be back with the winner in a
few minutes
natalie voted here with the host of the
gojo podcast mike golick jr happy to
have you here mike we're gonna kick
things off right away
my first question to you is if we give
you a hundred dollars right now said you
had to put it on either dak prescott to
win the mvp 16-1
or kurt cousins at 50-1 who would you
choose and why
so i understand a lot of people are high
on the vikings going into this season my
friends at football outsiders all love
them a lot of the numbers people think
they're going to make a jump i have seen
too much and i know too much about kirk
cousins at this point to throw any money
on something of this caliber on him give
me dak prescott on this one while the
cowboys are certainly going to have to
weather the storm up front tyron smith
and the injury in the offensive line
really throwing things out of whack some
quality lost on the defense from last
year i still think a healthy dak
prescott and this is really the first
time in his career he's been able to go
through training camp not rehabbing an
injury i think we're going to see the
talent that made him the guy that won
the job as a fourth round draft pick
initially and i think he's going to be
in position both because it's the
cowboys and because that offense is
going to have to rely even more on him
to make plays now that the offensive
line's a bit compromised and i think all
of that could lead to a world where if
the cowboys are still able to hang with
the philadelphia eagles who have been
gaining traction in this division it's
going to be because deck threw them into
that the way we saw maybe at the
beginning of the 2020 season
draftkings has a bet for any division to
have four playoff teams that's it plus
1200 what's the smart bet here
i think it would have to be the afc west
if you're going to get one
just because top to bottom we've got
maybe i don't think maybe the best
quarterback division in football i know
some people could maybe look over at the
afc north the ravens are going to
rebound after being according to
football outsiders one of the
historically most injured teams in the
nfl last season um but i just look and
say top to bottom russell wilson coming
over absolutely going to lift up that
broncos offense in the ways that we
expected derek carr and maybe all that
motivation after finding out he was the
one tom brady was talking about in that
trip to the shop gets the raiders to a
place where remember last year they were
a playoff team even with all the things
that they went to during the season so i
would take the afc west and i wouldn't
think too hard about it
tell us the team that you have no
interest in betting for or against this
season
complete stay away i'm talking about on
your do not bet list you just don't
trust him at all who is it
so i'm actually doing this more from my
heart than anything else because i'm
like a lot of people and i drank the
hard knocks kool-aid when it came to the
detroit lions i love this team i
actually think they're really well built
along the lines of scrimmage i think
what they've done there under dan
campbell has been a great example of
program building in the nfl but jared
goff is still the quarterback of that
team we saw them on the back end of so
many back-breaking losses last year and
while i think they're gonna be a thorn
in more sides than most i think the
public is going to feel a lot of that
hard knocks bump in the way that we look
at this and so i am trying right now to
be proactive and tell myself look but
don't touch with the lions i'm going to
have a great time watching and rooting
for that team they're america's team
this year but that doesn't mean that i
want to put any of my money on them
because there's still a lot of
inconsistency built into the model both
for that franchise's history and because
of the guy they have under center
trying to resist that hard knocks effect
i'm right there with you
but if you had to bet which is more
likely to happen this year we're going
to switch it up a little bit a team to
go winless
or
tom brady to retire in the middle of the
season which are you choosing
i would probably say a team to go
winless right like
the bears the falcons some of these
teams at the bottom of the barrel are
going to be really bad this season and i
just don't think for as much as it's
been a different year with tom brady and
we had him retired for 40 days and 40
nights like he's a character in the
bible and we had him miss 11 days of
training camp was everyone thought he
was the mass singer i i still don't see
him as the kind of guy that's going to
be able to walk away from a challenge in
front of him in the middle of the season
so betting against tom brady is usually
always a bad idea anyway so i'll rock
with one team unfortunately having to
taste the uh over uh cup here in the nfl
season and say that
so this season you can actually bet on
who will throw the most interceptions so
who should our audience be looking at
betting for that one
yeah so and it's interesting too because
you look up at the names at the top of
that list i think trevor lawrence and
matthew stafford were tied with 17 over
the course of last season and it makes
sense bad young quarterback on a team
that was dealing with the urban meyer
problem for matthew stafford he's a guy
that's always challenged people down
field and put the ball in some tough
spots because of the arm talent but
again just because of i think the
position they'll be this year i'll say
justin fields and the bears i think he
had 10 interceptions last season this is
a team that we saw in the preseason is
going to struggle to protect him all
year long i think is going to do a
better job than the prior administration
with matt nagy of still letting their
quarterback air it out trying to let him
make plays and use all the gifts that he
has but on that team i just think
there's going to be such an uphill
sledding that justin fields is in for a
really tough one and i hope it's not one
that ends up defining his young nfl
career because there is so much talent
ability there
incredible insight as always for those
at home make sure to check out mike's
gojo podcast with draftkings wherever
you listen to podcast and as always
great to have you on the show mike
appreciate you having me natalie thank
you
thank you natalie thank you mike uh hey
super bowl
i'm ready to get my pick man okay i'm
ready to talk my talk uh let's let's
talk the super bowl and give away our
vegas trip
i'ma go first no actually michael ritter
michael ritter i want you to go first
okay i've been it sounds like the chat's
liking me which is great yeah the chat's
loving getting a lot right off the bat
but i i think i think some people on
this set will like this pick so when i
look for the super bowl pick this year i
think that there are some definite
favorites look at the bills look the
packers
i think i'm gonna try to stay away from
the afc because i think the afc is just
stacked it's clearly the better
conference okay i think it's a little
tougher to find any value kind of thing
with that i'm going to go with the nfc
team that i think
roster wise is the best maybe in all of
football
i'm going with your san francisco 49ers
and i understand rookie
rookie quarterback i think kyle shanahan
this is a perfect situation for a rookie
quarterback i think he's going to put
him in great spots i think everyone
around him on that team the wide
receivers brandon nyu devos samuel the
running game is always going to be good
i have an amazing offensive line trent
best left tackle in the nfl and then
that defense i'm just i'm so excited to
watch the 49ers today
i think i believe what sixteen hundred
sixteen to one for our winners
i'm really curious what your pick's
gonna be but yeah i'm going with the
49ers as my super bowl pick this year oh
man michael ritter
i like you yeah all right we didn't get
off because we didn't start to show off
on the good foot but now we're jealous
hey calvin he said it i'm rocking with
the san francisco 49ers last year they
made it to the nfc championship game
with jimmy garoppolo as their
quarterback they basically have the same
roster they're bringing back the same
roster that defense is a championship
defense on paper on paper it's a
championship defense and most
importantly michael ritter i think they
improved at quarterback which was their
hiccup last year yeah we the 49ers
needed jimmy garoppolo to make a play
they were up 10 with 10 minutes left in
the fourth quarter in that nfc
championship game make one play he could
not make that play so i think that
they're going to get better at that
position
and uh i think they're going to get it
done man not no bias no bias i think
that they're going to get it done calvin
who do you think's walking away with
that lombardi trophy this year well
first i do like y'all's pick i don't
know how much faith i'll throw in the
quarter in the rookie quarterback's
hands but with kyle shanahan you know
that kind of gives you a little faith
there so i do i am you have me a little
bit more excited to see what uh trey's
gonna do out there um but i think the
super bowl was won last thursday
wow
wow
the bills the bills the bills that's
where you ride the low bill you think
they're gonna be able when it gets cold
when it gets cold they're gonna be able
to run the ball what do you mean they're
playing buffalo
if i had to pick a team from the afc i
the what we saw on thursday was amazing
yeah josh allen
you're just somebody you can trust
bill's bills niners super bowl yeah
that'd be sweet
we could bet that today if we wanted to
calvin i love you
i love that hey you heard it here first
go put the bets in bill's niners all
right it's time to give away that uh
vegas trip let's do it it's time to give
away that vegas trip and our lucky
winner
and i have to say i must say this
uh it's subject to verification so you
are subject to verification if you win
or not before the lawyers get mad at
they make me say that uh but the lucky
winner is drum roll
[Music]
s riley 99 and their super bowl pick was
to san francisco
hey no bias at
all it was completely random it was
completely random uh
but yeah hey shout out to my man that's
riley99 you are going to las vegas
take us with you maybe i was okay that's
why i was looking at you like i gotta go
you want to go
calvin michaels
uh tagging along yeah um hey
i think it's we've been here for a while
i think it might be time to get on the
bottom here man watch some pokemon go
soon getting close it's soon uh
we're at actually actually
more people want to tap in with you okay
in the comments i i gotta before i get
up out of here i gotta go to the
comments michael ritter i gotta go to
the comments and see what they were
talking about
uh
i'm in the comments right now my man
ryan is whipping up those comments he
says
calvin needs to be a weekly guest this
is awesome real buddha h-a-h-a says he
needs to be a i would love that have a
legend on with us every week that would
be awesome uh taking the under in the
lions game okay they're rocking with the
under in the lions game three he says
taking the under in the lions game i
don't know how we feel about that
my my birds they're going off today i
gotta i can't i can't root for an under
when i have a five spread so i'll
disagree there what
i'm conflicted
hey
a little controversy is going on in the
in in the comments they say all-time
team calvin or randy moss i'm taking
calvin
i'm saying
hey uh
we're at foxwoods yeah and so they have
people that roll into fox woods come
here and get and get put on shows and
entertain the got the people with they
got beach b-52s coming up b-52 i love
the b-52 michael ritter was giving me a
rundown
[Music]
tom jones okay tom jones is pulling up
to foxwoods make sure y'all come on down
the price is right bro i was watching
that as a kid yeah the price is right
i'm trying to be a
we should do that we should do that as a
content thing sometimes go on the prices
right that'd be fun there it is let me
know when y'all do that okay
we'll do that hey and make sure you guys
come check out the dk sports book here
at fox woods
for my friends calvin johnson the legend
the legend calvin johnson and also the
legend michael ritter
besides the kirk cousins pick
hey
we are out of here man peace out thanks
for tuning in
[Music]
[Music]
you